hi my name is avinash and i'm the author
of
the books web analytics 2.0 and webantic
scenario day i'm very excited to present
this webinar about web analytics to all
of you um
in this particular video i want to cover
the the incredible opportunity that
exists in using data online in solving
key business problems as well as
outlined for you some of the more
specific things that you can do once you
do start using web analytics and sort of
aspirationally all of the other more
wonderful things that are over the
horizon that you'll be able to take
advantage of once you start creating a
truly data driven business
now why would you want to do web
analytics a lot of people ask me this
question and honestly it surprises me
because
if you're not
wanting deeply profoundly desiring to be
data driven
then really there is no honest way to
survive in the world that we live in
today as
all different channels come together and
online continues to dominate growth for
companies and growth for non-profits as
a matter of fact but let me crystallize
why you should invest in web analytics
in a very simple way when you take out
an ad in a magazine and try and measure
its success in this case an ad for chevy
malibu all of the measures for success
are interpretive or proxy driven for
example you take out an ad in the time
magazine and the best proxy you have for
measuring success is the number of
subscribers the magazine has you have
absolutely no idea how many people might
have opened the magazine how many people
might have bothered to even see a
gorgeous little ad and and much less you
would know how many people then went to
a dealership and might have purchased uh
the product that you're selling in this
magazine ad but if you think about it
when you take out that exact same ad in
this case on google or yahoo or
microsoft or aol or or any other
property in the world the ad that shows
up right here at the very top it does
not require you to use your faith to
measure success you can use data to
measure success because you can measure
exactly how many people saw the ad you
can measure how many people clicked on
the ad how many people interacted with
the ad and finally if people do come to
your website as a result of this ad
you're able to measure how many people
customize the car set up a appointment
at the dealership downloaded a brochure
and all of the outcomes that are
available for that single ad that you
took so the measurement of success
rather than being interpretive and proxy
driven is direct
it is specific and it is scalable and i
cannot think of a better more powerful
and profound reason for you to use web
analytics than that it moves you away
from making business decision based on
faith and what you believe in to
shifting to using data and bringing a
massive amount of accountability to the
processes that you're executing for your
business
it behooves us to cover the definition
of web analytics so when we when we say
web analytics what do you mean and in
writing my second book i had created
this definition and the definition quite
simply says web analytics is the
analysis of qualitative and quantitative
data for your website and the
competition to drive continual
improvement of the online experience of
your customers and prospects which
translates into desired outcomes online
and offline and let me just highlight a
couple of different things in this
definition and the very first thing
that is important for all of us to
realize
is that we're talking about qualitative
as well as quantitative data most of the
time when people think about web
analytics they think about all the
clicks that we collect on the website
and while that continues to be one of
the larger sources of data we analyze uh
web analytics is also surveys and lab
usability testing and follow me homes
and
the various other
methodologies we can use to understand
why people behave the way they do on our
website it also includes analyzing your
competition one of the most amazing
things about the web is how much data
you have access to for all of your
competition
for any given website in the world you
can use tools like compete and trends
for websites and others to try and
understand how many people went to my
competitors website how long did they
stay and what did they do so that you
can learn from the analysis of data for
for your competitor and improve your
business also it's about improving
things every single day not opening
tools once in a while and and trying to
see if you can find something to change
but actually improving things every
single day in small bits and we're going
to cover this in this video and finally
it's about both online and offline while
the name
web at the word web exists in the name
web analytics web analytics is very much
about understanding the offline impact
of all of the online activities that you
do on your store on the phone center on
on sort of other existence you have like
a call center you might have offline but
it also means that web analytics is
great at understanding the online impact
of your offline activity such as
television campaigns and radio and
magazine ads and etc etc so it's
important to realize that web analytics
is not simply about analyzing the clicks
on of people who come to your website
but it's a much more expansive view of
qualitative and quantitative
competitive data in order to improve
your online existence
some people also think that it's really
really hard to get going and i think
this is one of the biggest biggest wrong
beliefs that people have if i want to
start by tracking a website in this case
let's say my blog arkham's razor all i
have to do is go to a web analytics tool
i could start with a free tool called
google analytics or a free tool called
yahoo's web analytics both really
wonderful tools i would simply open an
account i would copy this code from this
website from the google analytics or
yahoo analytics website literally i copy
these few lines of code i go back to my
website i open the footer file of my
website as you can see clearly it's in
this case i'm using a php driven website
photo.php i paste the code into this
file that i have on my website there you
go now you can see those exact lines of
code pasted into this into this file and
boom i sing happy birthday
right
of the data that you will need in order
to make decisions
using clickstream tools can be gotten
just by doing these three simple steps
on your website and any gorgeous data
flows in and you might perhaps be
thinking well what can i get for a few
lines of code right just a few reports
no that's the surprise here are all of
the reports that you can get from this
particular tool
uh google analytics in this case and and
i'm gonna hide with with little bit
transparently white all the data you
won't get if you do what i just said and
notice the massive amounts of data you
can get about visits and locations and
languages and mobile traffic and page
views and sources and keywords and
search engines girls at everything you
can get
so i hope that i've answered the
question
web
analytics and why right web first
analytic second y third you want to do
web analytics because it increases
accountability for the efforts you're
going to put on the web you want to do
web analytics because it lowers risk and
enables you to fail faster than anybody
else so that you win
at a greater magnitude than was ever
possible and you should do web analytics
because it is one of the most powerful
business drivers that will lead to a
long-term success for your business i
have yet to meet a single business that
is going to win on the web without
having a well-defined web analytics
process and strategy
thank you and i wish you all the very
best